[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend um
den mutmaßlichen Flugzeugabsturz des
söldnerchefs prigoshi ranken sich viele
Spekulationen manche vermuten gar das
Ganze sei vielleicht nur eine
Inszenierung solche Theorien gab es auch
schon bei seiner Meuterei vielleicht
auch weil es schwer fällt sich
vorzustellen dass einem Wladimir Putin
die Dinge außer Kontrolle geraten
könnten seine jahrzehntelange selbst
Inszenierung als allmächtiger wirkt weit
über die Grenzen Russlands hinaus dabei
ist Putin ja schon eine ganze Menge
außer Kontrolle geraten der Krieg in der
Ukraine läuft überhaupt nicht wie
geplant er hat mehrfach hohe Militärs
abgesetzt einer seiner wichtigsten
Generäle ist verschwunden auch
Topmanager wichtiger Unternehmen kamen
unter mysteriösen Umständen ums Leben
und nun mutmaßlich der langjährige
Weggefährte trigoshi Nina lieber geil
Bericht
für sie war er ein Held in St Petersburg
vor dem Hauptquartier der Söldnergruppe
Wagner legen Anhänger von Jewgeni
pregorian Blumen nieder trauern um ihn
der für sie kein brutaler Kämpfer
sondern ein echter Patriot war
es fühlt sich an als würde man einen
Vater verlieren er war alles für uns
denn alle haben immer darauf gewartet
was er sagen wird
sagte pregorian zu viel wurde er zu
mächtig zu unbequem während die Trümmer
am Tag nach dem Flugzeugabsturz
aufgeräumt werden nach den Ursachen
gesucht wird sind es diese Fragen die
Russland und die Welt beschäftigen
nur aus dem Kreml Schweigen es dauert
fast 24 Stunden bis Vladimir Putin sich
zu dem Flugzeugabsturz äußert den
Familien kontrolliert
ich kannte pregorian schon sehr lange
seit Anfang der 1990er Jahre er war ein
Mann mit einem komplizierten Schicksal
und er machte schwere Fehler im Leben
er spricht von Gregorian in der
Vergangenheitsform bestätigt den Tod
damit ihn direkt auf den Straßen Moskau
sind die Menschen skeptisch was sie
glauben sollen
es kann eine Inszenierung sein oder
vielleicht ist der wirklich gestorben
ich weiß nicht
das Flugzeug konnte nicht von selbst
abgestürzt sein irgendjemand hat das
alles möglich gemacht diese Meuterei und
so da hatte sich viel angehäuft auf
keinen Fall ist pregorian einfach so aus
dem Leben gegangen
vor zwei Monaten war Gregorian mit
seinen Söldnern auf Moskau marschiert
viele bejubelten ihn dafür
Putin spricht von Verrat dass der
russische Präsident Gregorian
schließlich Straffreiheit gewährte
überraschte viele hatte der wagner-chef
doch monatelang die Spitzen des
russischen Militärs beschimpft
vorgeführt öffentlich blamiert mit
seinem mutmaßlichen Putschversuch das
gesamte System Putin bloßgestellt konnte
der russische Präsident das wirklich
verzeihen in der Vergangenheit ließ
Putin daran zweifeln
ja aber nicht alles
wer Putin verrät muss wohl büßen das ist
die Botschaft die von diesem Tag bleibt
auch wenn noch sehr viele Fragen offen
sind
und darüber wollen wir mit einer
ausgewiesenen russland-expertin sprechen
mit Sabine Fischer von der Stiftung
Wissenschaft und Politik und Namen Frau
Fischer guten Abend Frau Slomka wir
hören Sie zu jedem Russland Kennern und
Beobachtern die nicht so wahnsinnig
überrascht waren dass Herrn pregorian
und kein sehr langes Leben mehr
beschieden war mutmaßlich also der
Zeitpunkt eines solchen Ereignisses
überrascht natürlich immer ein wenig
wenn man nicht morgens aufsteht und
denkt heute Nacht wird vom Himmel
geschossen aber die Tatsache dass er
umgekommen ist ist für mich nicht
sonderlich überraschend also sie gehen
auch davon aus dass er tatsächlich tot
ist
ich gehe jetzt erstmal davon aus dass er
tatsächlich tot ist weil aus meiner
Sicht mehr Indizien dafür sprechen als
dagegen aber man muss natürlich ganz
klar sagen dass wir keine vollständige
Information haben und man muss auch
damit leben wir alle müssen damit leben
dass wir die wahrscheinlich auch nie
vollständig haben werden sondern auf den
man Blicken der Motive hätte
auch schon ins Jenseits befördern zu
lassen Wladimir Putin die interpretieren
sie das dass der heute den Familien ja
kontrolliert
ich denke er knüpft damit an an das was
er einige Tage nach der pregorian
Meuterei gesagt hat er hat ja Wagner
sozusagen dann kurz nachdem diese
Meuterei passiert ist durchaus gelobt
hat die Leistungen war der der dieser
Söldnergruppe Wagner im Ukraine Krieg
hervorgehoben etc daran hat er heute
angeknüpft und vor allen Dingen denke
ich geht es für Putin und geht es für
das Regime darum die innenpolitische
Situation stabil zu halten und den
Menschen in Russland zu signalisieren
dass man diese Situation unter Kontrolle
hat und da passt für mich diese
kondolenzerklärung wenn Sie so wollen
durchaus mit rein könnte das dann
bedeuten dass Putin Angst hat auch vor
der wagnergruppe oder davor die populär
sie oder gregorien in der Bevölkerung
ist
ich denke Putin hat keiner oder ich
würde mich wundern wenn er Angst hätte
vor der wagnergruppe denn ich denke die
wagnergruppe hat in den letzten Monaten
schon deutlich an Bedeutung verloren und
wird jetzt noch weiter und schneller an
Bedeutung verlieren aber was die
Meuterei im Juni gezeigt hat war das
Putin eben keine vollständige Kontrolle
über die innenpolitische Situation in
Russland hat und insofern ist der
gestrige Tag
ein wichtiger in einschneidender Tag
gewesen was auch immer tatsächlich
passiert ist mit diesem Flugzeug im
Hinblick auch auf die russische
politische Elite denn natürlich gehen
die meisten Menschen denke ich in
Russland davon aus dass
das pregorian und utkin ermordet worden
sind und das ist natürlich ein Signal
auch an die politische Elite für den
Fall dass Menschen in Russland
Angehörige der Elite sich ähnliche
Gedanken machen könnten das war
sozusagen der zweite wichtige Mann der
damit an Bord war gewesen sein sollen
neben einer Reihe anderer auffällig war
ja auch dass die beiden oder alle zehn
die dann da an Bord waren oder acht im
Prinzip ähnlich starben wie die ähm
russischen Soldaten die in dem
Aufklärungsflugzeug saßen das wiederum
von den wagnergruppen während dieser
Meuterei vom Himmel geholt wurde als
auch die Bilder in ähnelten sich so dass
sie ihn in sozialen Medien sogar
verwechselt wurden könnte das nicht für
eine Form von Rache sprechen zu sagen du
stirbst jetzt so wie du unsere
Kampfpiloten der russischen Armee vom
Himmel geholt das kann man so
interpretieren es ist natürlich auch
tatsächlich am jahrestag des Beginns
dieser Meuterei passiert der auch das
könnte man so interpretieren aber wie
gesagt das ist ähm wir haben es mit
einem extrem undurchsichtigen
intransparenten System zu tun und
deswegen bin ich mit solchen
Interpretationen einfach vor sich denken
sie sagten ihm die wagnergruppe hat an
Bedeutung verloren in dem Kampf Umbach
Mut in der Ukraine spielte sie aber
eigentlich eine große Rolle
genau in der Schlacht um bachmut spielte
sie eine extrem große Rolle weil Wagner
natürlich auch die höchsten Kosten
getragen hat also auch die meisten
Verluste hatte und letztendlich als ja
Kanonenfutter für für die Streitkräfte
in dieser Schlacht um wachmund gedient
hat
bachmut ist dann eingenommen worden und
die Bedeutung von Wagner ist in diesem
praktischen Moment
bereits zurückgegangen Plus
hat sich ja vor allen Dingen im Frühjahr
in ein offenkonflikt mit der mit der
Führung der Streitkräfte begeben und
auch da sind Schritte ergriffen worden
um Wagner zu entmachten auch
institutionell um Wagner unter die
Kontrolle der Streitkräfte zu bringen
und die Meuterei und möglicherweise eben
auch das was gestern passiert ist können
durchaus auch in diesen Kontext gesehen
werden und mit dieser Enthauptung im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes von Wagner
gehe ich eigentlich davon aus dass
Wagner in Zukunft keine große Rolle mehr
spielen wird die Analyse der Russland
Expertin Sabine Fischer danke für das
Gespräch vielen
wie gesagt gestorben wird in Putins
Umfeld ziemlich viel alleinseits
Kriegsbeginn gab es wieder zahlreiche
mysteriöse Todesfälle innerhalb der
russischen Elite Leute die man
hierzulande vielleicht nicht kennt aber
es sticht halt doch sehr ins Auge wenn
wieder mal ein Oligarch aus einem
Fenster fiel eine besonders hohe
Sterblichkeit haben Regimekritiker und
Journalisten der lange Arm des
russischen Geheimdienstes reicht dabei
bis ins Ausland auch nach Deutschland
die europäischen Sicherheitsbehörden
scheinen da wenig Schutz zu bieten
umgekehrt ist Russland auch für
ausländische Journalisten ein
gefährliches berichtsgebiet geworden der
in Moskau inhaftierte
us-kovich vom Wall Street Journal wurde
heute früh erneut einem Gericht
vorgeführt Sebastian ihm berichtet
es ist kurz vor 9 Uhr als der
Transporter mit dem Journalisten Erwin
görschkowitsch vor dem Moskauer
stadtteilgericht le fuertevent kurz nur
ist der Inhaftierte US-Amerikaner zu
sehen wenn ich später melden russische
Medien die Untersuchungshaft wird um
weitere drei Monate verlängert es ist
natürlich auch unglaublich
enttäuschend
zu sehen was für einen hohen Preis
dieser Journalist zahlen muss nur dafür
dass er seine Arbeit gemacht hat die
Hoffnung auf eine baldige Freilassung
deshalb fast 150 Tagen Inhaftierten
goschkovic ist gering Anfang Juli gab es
in Moskau Gerüchte dass es einen
Austausch mit einem in den USA im
Gefängnis sitzenden Russen geben könnte
gremmelsprecher pisskopf bestätigte
Verhandlungen
es gibt bestimmte Kontakte in dieser
Hinsicht aber wir wollen sie nicht in
irgendeiner Weise an die Öffentlichkeit
bringen sie sollten in völliger Stille
durchgeführt und fortgesetzt werden doch
das US-Außenministerium stellte
vergangene Woche klar dass es dazu
nichts Neues zu berichten gibt das
Verhältnis mit Russland scheint auf
einem Tiefpunkt das Journalisten in
Putins Russland gefährlich leben ist
bekannt immer wieder werden sie
angeklagt festgenommen oder Opfer von
Anschlägen einer Politkowskaja ist das
prominenteste Beispiel sie wurde 2006
brutal ermordet
so sollte es auch Helena kostümchenko
gehen wie politkowska ja schrieb sie für
die Zeitung nur weil er garcierter weil
sie über Russlands Verbrechen in der
Ukraine berichtete wurde sie mit dem
Tode bedroht sie Flo aus Russland doch
im Oktober 2022 brach sie in Berlin
zusammen nach zahlreichen Untersuchungen
hatte eine Ärztin einen schrecklichen
Verdacht
sie sagte dass man alles mögliche
ausgeschlossen hätte und das bleibe ihr
nur eine Version
das sei eine von außen verursachte
Vergiftung und dann sagte sie man hat
sie möglicherweise vergiftet
Jelena hat überlebt sie hatte Glück im
Unglück aus Angst ist sie untergetaucht
mit uns spricht sie von einem geheimen
Ort
allein vier Mitarbeiter getötet
vier Menschen meine Kollegen
und ich verstehe Leute nicht die
Journalisten töten
doch Wladimir Putin kreiert sich seine
eigene Realität wer etwas anderes
berichtet kann sich nicht sicher fühlen
in Russland nicht und nun offenbar nicht
mal mehr im Ausland
der Wahl begeht die Ukraine heute einen
ihrer wichtigsten Nationalfeiertage den
Unabhängigkeitstag bezogen auf den 24
August 1991 als das Parlament in Kiew
den eigenständigen Staat Ukraine ausrief
dessen Territorium und teilbar und
unantastbar sei dazu gab es dann auch
eine Volksbefragung bei der insgesamt 90
Prozent der Bevölkerung Zuständen in
sämtlichen Landesteilen war das Votum
damals eindeutig auch in Donbass und
auch auf der Krippe
heute inmitten des Krieges hat dieser
Tag natürlich eine besondere emotionale
Bedeutung und die ukrainische Führung
präsentiert Erfolge die helfen die Moral
hochzuhalten Christian von Rechenberg
eine Kulisse wie geschaffen für einen
Tag der strahlende der starke Bilder
braucht weil er für die Ukraine so
wichtig ist vor der Sophienkathedrale
inszeniert der Präsident sich und sein
Land kämpferisch stolz es ist der zweite
Unabhängigkeitstag im Krieg
heute feiern wir alle den 32 jahrestag
der Unabhängigkeit der Ukraine 32 Jahre
ununterbrochener Unabhängigkeit die fort
bestehen wird die wir nicht zerreißen
lassen werden und die die Ukraine nicht
loslassen werden
Auszeichnung für Tapferkeit für ihn der
kämpfte
für Sie die den Mann den Vater verloren
haben
schweigen
eine Minute gedenkt das Land denen die
nie wieder heim kommen die gestorben
sind für ihre Freiheit
mein liebes Volk wir werden nicht
zulassen dass die ukrainische
Unabhängigkeit den Ukrainern aus den
Händen gleitet dieses Gefühl eint uns
alle wir kämpfen gegen den Feind und wir
wissen was wir tun können wir wissen wie
wir gewinnen können
und wir werden siegen
und so stehen auf Kias Straßen heute
erbeutete Panzer der Russen seither der
Gegner ist schwach
nordmaschinen als flanierkulisse das
soll wohl Mut machen
für mich hat sich die Bedeutung dieses
Festes komplett geändert früher war es
einfach ein nationales fest aber ich
habe mir nie darüber Gedanken gemacht
welchen Preis man für die Unabhängigkeit
bezahlt
wir kämpfen für das Recht auf unsere
eigene Identität für das Recht unsere
Zukunft in der Form zu haben wie wir sie
sehen es wäre gut wenn ich diese
Waffentechnik hier nicht sehen würde
nirgendwo in der Ukraine
wie gesagt ein Tag der Bilder braucht
auch diese hier zu sehen angeblich ein
ukrainisches Spezialkommando das in der
Nacht auf die besetzte Krim gelangt sein
will um dort Flagge zu zeigen und den
Gegner zu schwächen der heute wieder
mehrere Regionen mit geschossen angreift
mindestens 16 Menschen verletzt einen
tötet
es war auch der Tag der Solidarität mit
der Ukraine zum Fest verspricht etwa
Deutschland weiteren Beistand Norwegen
sagt Flugabwehrraketen zu womöglich auch
Kampfjets Signale die für Kiew heute
mindestens so wichtig sein dürften wie
eine strahlende Kulisse
[Musik]
und dann schalten wir noch zu unserer
reporterin Anne Brühl derzeit in harkev
anes das heißt ja immer wieder der
verteidigungswille der Ukrainer sei bei
allem Leid und Erschöpfung wirklich
ungebrochen und bist du als Reporterin
kreuz und quer durch die Ukraine gereist
auch ein Gebiete die hart und kämpft
sind wie nimmst du die Stimmung im Land
heute war
ruhig entschlossen sehr ernste denn den
Ukrainern wird schon immer klarer dass
dieser Krieg möglicherweise länger
dauern wird und dass sie dabei sind
einen sehr hohen Preis für die
Verteidigung dieser Unabhängigkeit zu
zahlen denn viele hier haben
Familienangehörige Freunde in diesem
Krieg verloren und trotzdem begegnen wir
auch immer wieder dieser
Entschlossenheit dieser russischen
Aggression etwas entgegenzusetzen es
gibt gerade eine neue Umfrage da
sprechen sich 90 Prozent der Ukrainer
dafür aus gegen Gebietsabtretungen von
Russland aus wir selbst wir waren jetzt
vor zwei Tagen in kopiens das ist hier
im Osten der Region hakif eine Stadt auf
die die Russen wieder vorrücken es gibt
Evakuierungen wir haben dort eine Frau
getroffen die hat uns erzählte ich habe
schon einmal russische Besatzung hier
erlebt ich habe wochenlang im Keller
gelebt hatte kein Brot nicht zu essen
das stehe ich nicht noch mal durch und
viele Ukrainer die wissen hier sehr
genau was auf dem Spiel steht danke
schön für diese Eindrücke
einen Erfolg kann Russland heute
verbuchen wobei Moskau dabei im
Windschatten Pekings steht die Chinesen
waren es die zuvorderst eine Erweiterung
der sogenannten brix-gruppe vorantrieben
sie soll einen sichtbar wachsendes
Gegengewicht zum Besten sein zu den
bislang fünf Mitgliedern kommen nun
sechs neue hinzu damit hat sich brixum
einen Schlag mehr als verdoppelt und das
soll erst der Anfang sein zu den neuen
im Bunde gehört das reiche Saudi-Arabien
aber auch Iran beide Länder waren sich
bislang Spinne Feind und führen einen
Stellvertreterkrieg im Jemen
gegeneinander aber auch die Verhältnis
anderer Mitglieder zueinander Bergen
konfliktstoffe berichten vom
Gipfeltreffen in Johannesburg
der rote Teppich stimmt schon mal aber
ist es auch der richtige Weg
für einen Moment war China so mächtiger
Herrscher bei diesem Gipfel
orientierungslos aber nur kurz am Ende
hat China bekommen was es wollte ein
stärkeres Bündnis gegen den Westen
am Morgen konnte Gastgeber Südafrika die
Erweiterung verkünden lange waren sich
die aufstrebenden Mächte uneinig
eigentlich sollte schon ein Ergebnis
präsentiert werden
wir haben eine Einigung erzielt über die
Leitprinzipien
standardkriterien und Verfahren des
bricks-erweiterungsprozesses
wir sind uns über die erste Phase der
Erweiterung einig weitere Phasen werden
folgen
zunächst kommen zu den fünf
bricks-staaten sechs neue dazu
Argentinien Ägypten
Äthiopien Saudi-Arabien die Vereinigten
Arabischen Emirate und Iran die brix+
stehen dann für 47% der Weltbevölkerung
und 37% der Weltwirtschaftsleistung
russlands Präsident Putin kann wegen
eines Haftbefehls des Internationalen
Strafgerichtshofs nicht persönlich dabei
sein per Video schalte war für dem
Westen vor sich mit allen Mitteln gegen
die aufstrebenden Mächte und eine
multipolare Welt zu
wehrenialismus in neuer Verpackung der
übrigens nicht so gut aussieht mit
Slogans wie Demokratie und
Menschenrechten wollen die modernen
Kolonisatoren ihre Probleme lösen und
das auf Kosten anderer
[Musik]
vor allem die Aufnahme Irans wird als
politische Statement gegen den Westen
interpretiert wie die bisherigen
bricks-staaten will auch Iran die
internationale Dominanz des US-Dollars
brechen
die Islamische Republik Iran unterstützt
sehr stark das bricks Bestreben der
endgalerisierung beim Handel und
wirtschaftlichen Kontakten zwischen den
Mitgliedern sollten stattdessen die
jeweiligen Landeswährungen benutzt
werden
die Erweiterung der Gruppe ist ein Sieg
vor allem für China und Russland sie
hatten darauf gedrängt um im Wettstreit
mit dem Westen möglichst viele Länder
auf ihrer Seite zu haben der meinen
Experten müsste sich jetzt bewegen
der Westen sagt oft dass er sich
gleichberechtigt sieht mit den Ländern
des globalen Südens dass er seine
Beziehungen mit dem globalen Süden
vertiefen will und ich glaube dass das
für den Westen jetzt mehr werden muss
als bloße Rhetorik
doch auch für die brix-staaten ist die
Erweiterung mit großen Aufgaben
verbunden schon jetzt dringend
unterschiedlich große Wirtschaften
miteinander Demokratien mit Autokratien
gemeinsame Entscheidungen dürften
künftig noch schwieriger werden und doch
haben mich China und die übrigen bricks
vorerst ihren Weg gefunden und sind
ihrem Ziel eine multipolaren Welt ein
Stück näher gekommen
und jetzt geht es erstmal bei dir weiter
Heinz mit dem Blick nach Deutschland in
der Diskussion über einen
subventionierten industriestrompreis
kommt jetzt auch ein Vorstoß von der
SPD-Fraktionsspitze sie schlägt vor
angelegt auf fünf Jahre zunächst 5 Cent
pro Kilowattstunde für ausgewählte
Branchen unterschiedliche Reaktionen bei
den Koalitionspartnern grünen
Fraktionschefin dröge sagte sie freut
sich dass sich die
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion hinter die Idee
des industriestrompreises von Robert
Habeck gestellt habe Widerspruch dagegen
von FDP-Chef Finanzminister Lindner der
sich am Rande eine Veranstaltung in
Sachsen-Anhalt äußerte
der Wirtschafts- und stabilisierungsform
kann dafür nicht zur Verfügung stehen
das ist rechtlich ausgeschlossen im
übrigen bin ich auch im Zweifel ob es
sinnvoll sein kann einzelne große
Stromverbraucher zu subventionieren und
am Ende zahlen die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger zahlen die mittelständischen
Betriebe dafür die Kosten da müssen wir
uns bessere Wege einfallen lassen zu
bezahlbarer Energie
ein Bündnis aus Sozialverbänden und
Gewerkschaften fordert eine Pflege
Vollversicherung denn mit der
derzeitigen Regelung sind die
Zuzahlungen Pflegebedürftiger immer mehr
gestiegen so waren es im ersten heimjahr
im bundesweiten Schnitt im ersten halben
Jahr genau im ersten heimjahr im
bundesweitenschnitt gut 2.500 Euro pro
Monat deshalb eine Auswertung des
Verbandes der Ersatzkassen nach einer
von Sozialverbänden heute vorgestellten
Umfrage befürchten mehr als 80% ein
Pflegeheim nicht finanzieren zu können
und sind dafür die Pflegeversicherung zu
einer Vollversicherung auszubauen
mehrere Bewerber um die
Präsidentschaftskandidatur der
US-Republikaner sind bei einer ersten
Fernsehdebatte gegeneinander angetreten
zu den acht Teilnehmern gehörten
Ex-Präsident Pants und Floridas
Donald Trump blieb der Debatte fern er
gab stattdessen ein langes
Einzelinterview das zur gleichen Zeit im
Internet veröffentlicht wurde unter den
republikanischen Bewerbern liegt Trump
in Umfragen deutlich vorne
und Donald Trump gilt heute erneut große
Aufmerksamkeit er muss sich im
Zusammenhang mit einer Anklage wegen des
Vorwurfs der versuchten
Wahlbeeinflussung im Bundesstaat Georgia
im Bezirksgefängnis in Atlanta melden es
wird erwartet dass er in den nächsten
Stunden dort eintrifft und nach der
Aufnahme seiner Personalien kann er die
Stadt wieder verlassen
zwölf Jahre nach der Reaktorkatastrophe
von Fukushima ist dort heute damit
begonnen worden aufbereitetes Kühlwasser
ins Meer zu leiten trotz der Proteste
von fischereiverbänden und
Nachbarstaaten wie China bislang wurde
das belastete Kühlwasser auf dem Gelände
gelagert inzwischen gehe dort aber der
Platz aus erklärte die japanische
Regierung auch die internationale
atomenergieagentur hatte grünes Licht
gegeben für die Einleitung in den
Pazifik
wer früher das heißt bis in die 1990er
Jahre Grimms Märchen las für den war der
Wolf eben genau das ein märchenhaftes
Wesen das wahlweise Rotkäppchens
Großmutter oder die sieben Geißlein
bedrohte aber kein Tier das real durch
deutsche Wälder streift
das hat sich gründlich geändert seit der
Jahrtausendwende sind die Wölfe zurück
und verbreiten sich in manchen Regionen
sogar ziemlich stark und auch wenn der
Wolf zu Unrecht das boshafte Märchen
Image mit sich herumträgt
unproblematisch ist das nicht
Niedersachsen wo es besonders viele
Wölfe gibt drängt die Politik auf
Lösungen im September will sich eine
ganze
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz dem Thema
widmen
mehr als 1.500 Wölfe streunen
mittlerweile durch Deutschland die
Wolfspopulation steigt stetig das war
auch so geplant der Wolf ein Atemschutz
Erfolg er ist nach 150 Jahren wieder da
er ist aber auch ein Reizthema geworden
im Jahr 2022 gab es erstmals über 4.000
verletzte und getötete Nutztiere
darunter neben scharfen auch
ziegenrinder und Pferde im letzten Jahr
haben Wölfe so viele Weidetiere in
Deutschland angegriffen wie noch nie
22 Mal war der Wolf hier in Suderburg in
der Lüneburger Heide bei Schäfer
Karlheinz Jahnke er hat schon viele
wolfsangriffe auf seine Schafherden
erlebt Janke kommt nicht mehr zu Ruhe
man ist ein bisschen enttäuscht und
resigniert auch ein bisschen weil das
schon über so einen langen Zeitraum gibt
man gibt ganz einfach auf so weil also
ich sehe auch kein Licht im Horizont um
seine Herde zu schützen muss er immer
wieder aufrüsten doch der Wolf
überspringt mittlerweile seine
Schutzzäune von der Politik führt er
sich im Stich gelassen weniger Wölfe
wären für ihn die Lösung das fordern
auch nutztierverbände
Horst Günther jahrgau kann die Forderung
der Schäfer verstehen er ist Jäger
kümmert sich um die Tierbestände in
seinem Revier der Wolf muss wie jede
andere Wildart eine Jagd und eine
Schonzeit bekommen fordert er wir haben
in Niedersachsen im Moment 500 Wölfe
plus X und 33% Zuwachs jedes Jahr wird
das irgendwann an die Grenzen kommen
also das kann so denke ich nicht gehen
und ich glaube auch nicht dass die Jäger
dran erwischt sind keine Wölfe zu haben
wir Jäger können mit den Wölfen leben
das ist kein Thema aber nicht in dieser
Menge was Bestände zu regulieren dass es
nicht erlaubt Wölfe stehen unter
strengen im Naturschutz und dürfen nur
in Einzelfällen geschossen werden das
soll auch so bleiben fordern Verbände
wieder NABU mehr Wölfe abzuschießen oder
gar ganze Rudel das sei der falsche Weg
der Naturschutzverband verweist auf
Umfragen die Akzeptanz für den Wolf in
der Gesellschaft ist hoch
70 Prozent der Bevölkerung begrüßt das
wir bemerken auch nicht seitdem eine
Änderung in der Bevölkerung übrigens
auch zwischen Land und Stadt kein
Unterschied aber es gibt eben einen
kleinen Teil in der Bevölkerung der das
ablehnt abgelehnt hat und auch weiterhin
ablehnen wird der Wolf polarisiert im
ostfriesischen Aurich gab es im Juni
eine Anti wolfsdemonstration mehr als
3000 Landwirte forderten sogar
wolfsfreie Zonen Niedersachsen erhöht
nun den Druck auf den BUND fordert
schnellere Lösungen und ein regionales
Bestandsmanagement heißt Wölfe sollen
künftig in bestimmten Regionen wie hier
an der Küste abgeschossen und
umgesiedelt werden können der Wolf
gehört nach Deutschland das müssen wir
schützen aber wir müssen in Einzelfällen
die Möglichkeit auch haben zum Beispiel
zum Schutz von deichscharfen
regional differenziert handeln zu können
die Schafe spielen hier eine wichtige
Rolle für den Deichschutz sie halten das
Gras kurz und treten den Boden fest
gerade hier nehmen wolfsrisse zu
und jetzt noch der Blick auf die
Finanzmärkte Heinz mit der Frage was
haben die großen Notenbanken in Sachen
Zinsen vor antworten oder zumindest
Hinweise werden von einem
spitzentreffenden Jackson Hole in den
USA erwartet Frank Bethmann hat das im
Blick und schaut vor allem wo rauf ja
auf die Inflation das ist das große
Thema unter den Notenbankern war es im
Übrigen bereits im vergangenen Jahren
gleicher Stelle als der Mann der vor
allem im Mittelpunkt steht der
US-amerikanische Zentralbankchef Jerome
Paul die Märkte auf einen harten Kampf
gegen die Inflation einstimmte nun sind
die zurückliegenden 12 Monate aus Sicht
der Währungshüter gut gelaufen Schafe
Leitzinserhöhung haben dazu geführt dass
der Preisdruck nachgelassen hat obwohl
er immer noch da ist ist denn davon
auszugehen dass es weitere
Zinserhöhungen geben wird oder ist der
Gipfel erreicht naja um es mit Christine
lagard der französischen EZB Präsidentin
zu sagen also eine Leitzins Senkung kann
sie definitiv aus wir wissen das sagte
sie auf der letzten Sitzung im Juli
alles andere ist offen und genauso wird
es Jerome Paul bei seiner Rede halten
nur nicht festlegen was man machen wird
beide Lagarde und Paul werden morgen
ihren großen Tag in Jackson Hole haben
die Märkte hoffen auf kleine vielleicht
versteckte Hinweise ohne die ging der
DAX heute erst einmal in Deckung verlor
über 100 Punkte und rutschte auf
15.621 Zähler ab auch der Dow Jones
Index am Abend im Rückwärtsgang keiner
wagt sich zu früher aus der Deckung so
müssen wir uns mit einer Umfrage unter
Ökonomen begnügen die sehen den
zinsgipfel mehrheitlich erreicht also
keine weiteren sind Erhöhung
vielen Dank
es gibt aktuelle Unwetterwarnungen des
Deutschen Wetterdienstes für Teile von
Baden-Württemberg und Bayern gewarnt
wird vor schweren Gewittern mit
Orkanböen Starkregen und Hagel
ein Ergebnis vom Fußball für Eintracht
Frankfurt gab es am Abend im Playoff
Hinspiel in der Konferenz liegt bei
Sophia eins zu eins Unentschieden die
Entscheidung für das Weiterkommen fällt
am kommenden Donnerstag in Frankfurt
die Deutschen hockeyfrauen haben bei der
Heim-EM in Mönchengladbach das Finale
verpasst sie verloren am Abend gegen
Belgien mit Null zu eins
Bundestrainer Altenburg hat einiges zu
erklären in diesem Halbfinale weil
Belgien frühen Führung geht ungewohnt
und das erste Gegentor überhaupt für die
deutschen Frauen bei dieser EM
Deutschland variantenreich bei Strafe
Ecken Charlotte stapenhaus aber bringt
den Ball nicht über die Linie und trifft
im letzten Viertel nur den Pfosten in
der Gruppenphase noch hatte Deutschland
den besten Angriff heute aber sind es zu
viele Ballverluste zu viele technische
Fehler in der Schlusssekunde ist es
Belgiens heute in die den Ausgleich
verhindert Deutschland spielt am Samstag
um Bronze
ärgerlich
[Applaus]
das war's von uns gleich im Anschluss
folgt die Doku die streitrepublik sie
beobachtet wie sich die politischen
Polarisierungen in unserer Gesellschaft
bisschen Familien hinein auswirken und
gegen 00:15 Uhr
[Musik]
guten Abend jetzt stürzen Wetter und
Temperaturen ab die schwule Hitze mit 30
bis 35 Grad wird bis Montag in Richtung
Südosteuropa abgedrängt und dann wird es
von Nordwesten deutlich kühler mit nur
noch Höchsttemperaturen von 15 bis 20
Grad und das geht einher mit kräftigen
Gewittern es hat allerdings auch zur
Folge dass die Nächte nicht mehr so warm
sind wie in den vergangenen heute Nacht
sinken die Werte auf 19 bis 16 Grad noch
mal eine tropische Nacht jetzt hier in
Thüringen oder auch am Rhein mit 20 oder
21 Grad heute Nacht gibt's zum Teil
kräftige Regenfälle und vielleicht auch
mal ein unwetterartiges Gewitter also
eines das mit Starkregen und Sturm Böden
verbunden ist am ehesten trocken bleibt
die Nacht hier im Nordosten und morgens
ziehen dann jede Menge Regenschauer und
Gewitter von Südwest nach Nordost über
uns hinweg die können prinzipiell jeden
treffen am längsten freundlich bleibt es
wohl noch im Norden Schleswig-Holsteins
der Winter zu kommt aus südwestlichen
und die Temperaturen liegen morgen an
der Nordsee bei 20 bis 22 Grad sonst
werden 24 bis 32 Grad erreicht es wird
also auch morgen noch mal heiß besonders
hier im südlichen Brandenburg auch in
der Lausitz und auch in Niederbayern und
dann wird es von Tag zu Tag kälter über
das Wochenende und am Montag erwarten
uns dann Höchsttemperaturen von nur noch
14 bis 22 Grad und dazu wird es deutlich
wechselhafter guten Abend